(logo swooshing)
(clicking and beeping)
(slow piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical eight.
Bipedal, naked, large-brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here,
an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(lively music)
- In the 1860s or so, a Scottish essayist
who I'm very fond of, Alexander Smith,
wrote, "It is our knowledge
that we have to die
"that makes us human."
Couple of decades later,
William James in the 1890s,
he called death
"The worm at the core of
the human experience."
Then if we fast forward
a couple of decades,
almost a century after that, in the 1970s,
the cultural anthropologist Ernest Becker,
he won a Pulitzer Prize for
his book The Denial of Death,
in which he basically
elaborated on that basic idea,
it is our knowledge that we
have to die that makes us human.
He did so by trying to frame these ideas
in both an evolutionary
as well as an existential,
psychodynamic fashion.
What Becker does, even though
this may sound a tad dated,
given some of the ideas that we've already
been exposed to today,
is to just start with, I think,
the relatively simple Darwinian assumption
that people are very similar
to all other forms of life
in that we're biologically
predisposed to survive,
both in the interest of self-preservation
as well as reproducing and
extending our genes over time.
On the other hand, Darwin
noticed very early on
that there's lots of ways,
over billions of years of evolution,
that different forms of
life have accomplished
that most arduous task
of persisting over time.
So everything from the turtle shells
to the eagle's eyesight.
It raises the question of well, what is it
that is responsible for
our fantastic success?
The answer is, there's lots of things,
both physical and psychological,
including our relatively large forebrain
that gives us the capacity
to think abstractly and symbolically,
to the point, Becker notes,
that only human beings,
as far as we can tell,
can imagine something
that doesn't yet exist
and then have the audacity
to take our dreams
and render them into reality.
Some of you probably, I
see a few head shakes.
I know it's late in the day.
Who's seen Da Vinci's
drawings of helicopters
in the 1500s?
When he did that, people
said, "Wow, that's crazy."
And yet today, we are
routinely transported
by what was originally denounced
as the doodlings of madmen.
So abstract symbolic thought has certainly
served us very well.
I like how Otto Rank, one
of Freud's disciples, put it
when he said that only human
beings make the unreal real.
What Becker then does, though,
is to move back in time
a couple of decades
and to think about this
idea in light of the Danish
existential philosopher Soren Kierkegaard.
It was Kierkegaard who pointed out
that human beings are so smart
that we come to realize that we exist.
Self-awareness, a complex theory of mind,
the way that Kierkegaard put it,
it takes a ridiculously
sophisticated cognitive apparatus
to render yourself the object
of your own subjective inquiry.
What Kierkegaard did in a little book
called Fear and Trembling
that I always recommend
you buy for your in-laws'
coffee table as a holiday gift,
(audience laughs)
what Kierkegaard said was that there are
emotional ramifications of
being explicitly self-aware.
He described them as being
both awesome and dreadful.
Kierkegaard said, "You know what?
"It's really great to be
self-aware and to be alive."
Who's ever had one of those magic moments,
you wake up on a beautiful day like today,
you didn't win a Nobel Prize,
you didn't win a great fortune,
and yet you're just sublimely appreciative
of the fact that you're alive?
Everybody does look pretty happy today.
I grew up
(audience laughs)
in New Jersey, so it's a little dicier.
But I think for the most part,
we all understand just the sublime
and spontaneous exuberance
that comes from being alive
and knowing that we're here.
On the other hand,
Kierkegaard turns right around
and he says, "Yeah, but it's also dreadful
"to be alive and to know it,
"because lest ye be either a small child
"or neurologically impaired,
"if you're smart enough
to know that you're here,
"you're also smart enough to know that,
"like all living things, your
life is of finite duration.
"Moreover, you're smart enough to realize
"that your life could end at any time
"for reasons that you could
never anticipate or control,
"and that from a purely
biological perspective,
"you are a breathing
piece of defecating meat
"that is no more fundamentally
significant or enduring
"than a lizard or a potato."
(audience laughs)
What Becker argued is that
the explicit awareness
of the reality of the human condition,
we will all someday die,
we can die at any time,
we're breathing pieces of
meat, cold cuts with attitudes,
we're Spam,
(audience laughs)
we're the plan but we got no can,
would literally debilitate us
with paralyzing existential terror.
What Becker proposed is that human beings
manage the terror that is engendered
by the awareness of their mortality
by embedding ourselves in
what the anthropologists call
culture, humanly constructed beliefs
about the nature of reality
that we share with our
fellow human beings,
that give us a sense that life had meaning
and that we have value.
What Becker points out
as an anthropologist is
that all cultures have a story or accounts
of the origin of the universe.
All cultures have prescriptions
for how we ought behave while we're here.
All cultures offer hope of immortality,
either literally through the having souls
and afterlives of the
world's great religions,
or symbolically through the belief that,
while you may not be here and
I may not be here forever,
we're comforted by the prospect
that some manifestation of our existence
will persist over time,
perhaps from having children,
perhaps from amassing great fortunes,
perhaps from producing great
works of art and science.
Moreover, what culture does for us
is to give us each social roles
with associated standards of conduct
that, if we meet or exceed them,
allow us to think that
we're persons of value
in a world of meaning.
And when we do think
that way about ourselves,
Becker called that self-esteem.
His argument is that because
our beliefs about the world
and because self-esteem are so important
that whether we're aware of it or not,
most of our behavior from day to day
is motivated in the service
of maintaining those beliefs.
Two questions.
One question is, so what?
The other question is,
is any of this true?
The so what question in our
world is generally framed
in terms of conceptual power.
What is it that you could understand
if you momentarily accept the
veracity of Becker's claims
that might be less easy
to understand otherwise?
And then the second question is,
well is there any evidence
in support of these views?
What we did, and when I say "we," I mean
my buddies Jeff Greenberg, now
at the University of Arizona
and Tom Pyszczynski, now at
the University of Colorado
at Colorado Springs,
we developed a very simple
laboratory paradigm.
It's called the Mortality
Salience Paradigm.
The logic, I think, is disarmingly simple.
We just said, "All right.
"If these ideas are correct,
if our beliefs about reality
"serve to mitigate death anxiety,
"well, let's bring people into the lab
"and let's remind them
that they're going to die,
(audience laughs)
"in controlled conditions.
"Let's remind them," it's
not as gory as it sounds,
"let's remind them in
controlled conditions
"of something unpleasant but not fatal."
For students, think about your next exam.
For regular people, think
about going to the dentist
and needing a root canal
without anesthesia.
Think about being in a car crash
and having a limb amputated.
All unpleasant but not particularly fatal.
In our typical paradigm,
we bury in a bunch
of personality scales
two open-ended questions.
"Please briefly describe the emotions
"that the thought of your
own death arouse in you,"
and "jot down, as specifically as you can,
"what you think will happen
to you as you physically die."
We do this in a lot of ways, though.
Sometimes we'd go outside the lab
and we stop people either
in front of a funeral parlor
or 100 meters to either side,
thinking that, when you're
in front of a funeral parlor,
death may be on your mind
even if you don't know it.
Then the most subtle paradigm,
we call it subliminal death primes,
if you come to my office at Skidmore,
you can read your email.
And while you're doing that,
we'll flash the word "death"
for 28 milliseconds,
so fast that you don't know
that you have been exposed
to that rather unwelcome stimulus.
That's what we do.
All of these methods
produce the same outcomes.
Let's briefly talk about
some of the areas of inquiry.
A lot of them Ad-jeep mentioned
earlier in his fine talk.
So what do we know based on
almost 40 years of research?
Our original interest
was trying to understand
why people can't get
along with other people
who don't share their beliefs
about the nature of reality.
What Ernest Becker said in a
book called Escape from Evil
is that other people pose
an existential challenge
to our belief systems,
because if you accept
an alternative conception of a reality,
you do so by undermining the confidence
with which you subscribe to your own.
And when you do that,
you undermine the beliefs
that serve to minimize your anxiety.
What he proposed is that,
when we run into people
who are different, the first thing we do
is to denigrate or belittle them.
While we do that, we
simultaneously try to get them
to get rid of their ideas
and adopt ours instead.
If that doesn't work,
just kill those people,
thus proving that my God
is better than your God
and we will kick your ass to prove it.
Now, in support of that view,
what we know in several 100 studies
conducted all over the world by our people
and independent researchers,
is, for example, Christians
reminded of their mortality,
they like fellow Christians a lot more
and they hate Jewish people.
If you go to Israel and
remind Jewish people
of their mortality,
they love Jewish people
and they hate Arabs and Christians.
Germans reminded of their mortality
sit closer to fellow Germans
and they sit further away
from people who look
like Turkish immigrants.
Iranians reminded of their mortality
become more supportive of suicide bombers
and more willing to become
a suicide bomber themselves.
In America, as you know,
we're very practical.
We're not about to blow ourselves up,
but we're happy to blow up other people.
When we remind Americans
of their mortality,
they become more supportive
of the preemptive use
of biological, nuclear
and chemical weapons
against countries who pose
no direct threat to us.
Another area of inquiry for us,
(audience laughs)
that's not funny,
has been understanding
how existential anxieties
have a radical effect on
political preferences.
Max Weber, the German sociologist
at the beginning of the 20th century,
coined the term "charismatic leader."
He said that in times
of historical upheaval,
when existential anxieties
are apt to be aroused,
that we often embrace a
certain kind of seemingly
larger than life leader,
who he called charismatic,
and he said that very
often these are people
who believe to be either divinely ordained
or self-appointed, in order
to rid the world of evil.
We got interested in this
in the aftermath of September 11, 2001.
Old timers may remember
than in a three-week period,
President George W. Bush
went from the least liked
to the most like President
in American history.
We did a lot of studies leading
up to the 2004 election,
where we showed that Americans preferred
Senator John Kerry to President Bush
in a benign state of mind.
However, when they were reminded
of their mortality first,
they liked President Bush a whole lot more
than Senator Kerry.
Ditto in this election.
This summer, we found in several studies
that our respondents
preferred Secretary Clinton
to now-President Trump
when they were in a psychologically
benign state of mind.
However, when they were reminded
of their mortality first,
their affection and support
for President Trump increased
and they now liked him more
than they did Secretary Clinton.
Let's keep going and let's
see how death anxiety
fosters an alienation from nature
and contempt for the environment.
John Locke in the 1890s,
in the second treatise on
government, pointed out
that anything that's natural
is of finite duration.
Of course, that's what we chafe at
and that may have been
the psychological impetus
for the construction of the supernatural.
To the extent that that's true,
when death is on our mind, we
should chafe at the prospect
that we're animals and we should
be uncomfortable in nature.
And that's exactly what we find.
People who are reminded of their mortality
take issue with claims
that humans are animals.
They have more negative
attitudes towards animals
and think it's okay to kill them
for reasons other than
food and medical research.
People reminded of their mortality
become more uncomfortable
when they're out in nature,
and people reminded of their mortality
become more willing to greedily exploit
non-renewable natural resources.
Of course, we can't talk
about the plundering
of the environment without
a concurrent consideration
of our seemingly insatiable
desire for money and stuff.
I like how Big Daddy in Cat
on a Hot Tin Roof put it
when he said, "The human
animal is a beast that dies
"and if he's go money, he
buys and buys and buys,
"and I think the reason he
buys everything that he can buy
"is that in the back of his
mind he has the crazy hope
"that one of his purchases
will be life everlasting."
Research shows that Big
Daddy's right on the money.
People reminded of their mortality say
that they have higher fiscal aspirations.
They say it would take more money
before they would perceive
themselves as wealthy.
People reminded of their
mortality want more stuff,
not just any stuff, they want
high-status luxury items,
like a Lexus and a Rolex.
When people are reminded
of their mortality,
and you ask 'em to draw pictures of money,
they draw bigger pictures,
as if money looms larger
when death is on their mind.
Just giving people money to count,
not to keep, just counting money,
reduces death anxiety.
If you like cookies
(audience laughs)
and you're reminded of
death, you eat more cookies.
If you smoke cigarettes and
you're reminded of death,
you smoke more cigarettes.
If you drink alcohol and
you're reminded of death,
you drink more alcohol.
Well, so what?
Thomas Hardy, one of my
favorite novelists, said,
"If a way to the better there be,
"it comes from taking a
close look at the worst."
Just to follow up on some of the things
that Ar-jeep talked about
at the end of his talk,
I would argue that
malignant manifestations
of death anxiety surely do
not bring out the best in us.
They seem to turn us into
hateful, war-mongering
proto-fascists plundering the planet
in our insatiable quest
for dollars and draws in a
television-alcohol-drug-Facebook-Twitter-induced
stupor.
(audience laughs)
Danny Brower might be right in 2007,
when he said that "Wow,
an ironic effect of RZO
"to deny death may be that
we are the first form of life
"to have the ignominious distinction
"of being responsible for our extinction."
All right, having said that, though,
let me close on a more positive note
and just point out,
(audience laughs)
usually I stop now and I go,
"All right, thank you
very much, let's drink."
On a more positive note, though,
human beings, we have a good
track record historically
of extricating ourselves
from some very difficult circumstances
once we understand what underlies them.
In the Middle Ages, when
people were dropping like flies
from the plague, when we
thought that it was caused
by evil spirits, we really
didn't get anywhere.
On the other hand, when we
realized that it was bacteria,
then we were able to develop penicillin,
and that led to modern medicine.
Similarly, what I would like to think,
even if this appears naively optimistic,
is that if we could
collectively come to recognize
the incredible problems
that excessive death denial has produced,
then maybe we can also collectively deploy
our remarkable creativity and ingenuity
in order to nudge our
species into a more benign
or maybe even more benevolent direction.
I like how Camus put it.
"Come to terms with death.
"Thereafter anything is possible."
Maybe an overstatement,
but no harm in using this
as a standard to approximate.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)